will Jen madame roola
welcome to Copenhagen and welcome to the
black diamonds when when you mentioned
this building in English it sounds more
like a James Bond movie than than a
building actually we are here to talk
about populism and and we've got to sort
of narrow it from a theoretical
standpoint about what is populism and
then we're gonna talk about current
affairs what's happening in Europe
what's happening in the Middle East
what's happening in in America as well
so we'll try to use your sort of
theoretical wisdom and and your historic
perspective to look at the world as as
of today so first of all I'd like you to
define the term populism well first of
all thank you for the warm welcome and
thank you for presuming wisdom on my
part I hope I can make good on that
rather grand promise so how to define
how to define populism there is no as
many of you will know there is no
universally agreed definition of
populism among social scientists
historians poker commentators today my
take on the phenomenon results in a
somewhat narrower concept of populism
than many other people would propose I
think it's actually a political problem
in Europe in particular today that the
concept of a designation populism tends
to get overstretched everything from the
Spanish indignados to let's say the
Greek syriza party are called populist
and I think many of these parties
movements individuals are in fact not
populist so what is a populist my
definition or my approach to it would
say that populism works with a
particularly moral conception of
politics it pits
a homogeneous innocent usually
hard-working fully unified people
against an elite that is of course
defined on the contrary terms
so usually corrupt usually not working
not serving the people and very often
not really properly belonging to the
people at all very often that in
right-wing populism in particular one
sees that image of the elite combined
with a further so to speak enemy of the
people and those are those who are at
the very bottom of society who of course
in the populist imagination also don't
really work and don't really properly
belong let me give you from a one
concrete example of that in a number of
Eastern European countries for instance
the populist imagination precisely
combines post-communist usually
left-wing elites with those at the very
bottom or at the very margin of society
hugely the Roma and these sort of two
co-leading parts then also are often in
the populist imagination supported by an
illegitimate outside power in the case
here of course the European Union and
maybe maybe others too but you see the
same phenomenon for instance in the
United States where for a long time the
populist imagination sort of suspected a
secret called collusion between liberal
in the American sense of the word
liberal so somewhat left-wing social
democratic bicoastal elites and African
Americans at the very bottom of society
and the sort of absolute populist
nightmare came of course true when these
two were embodied in one man you know
both an African American and a Harvard
elite person yeah so for them this is
sort of for the populist this is the
worst possible scenario exactly but when
we talk about populism in Europe and in
the United States as well when you refer
to the Tea Party movement we talk about
right-wing nationalistic movements can
you give any examples of left-wing
socialist populist party or movement
they're far fewer then is usually
assumed
so for instance it's very often said
that in France there's a kind of
symmetry between the four national under
marine lepen and some money like mellow
song who was seen as a left-wing
populist versus lepen as a right-wing
populist I think that kind of symmetry
usually doesn't work if you are willing
to go with my understanding of populism
because then you might still find lots
of things wrong with a character like
mellow sure you might say the policy
proposals are simplistic or you don't
like the rhetoric for other reasons but
it doesn't have that particularly
exclusionary move that I think is
central to populism it also doesn't have
a characteristic which I think if I may
I would I would add further namely that
contrary to what some people sometimes
say that well populism maybe sometimes
it's distasteful but it's a kind of
useful corrective for liberal democracy
because it's really an attempt to bring
the people in to make the people speak
to make the people participate and as
good Democrats we all really want
participation I don't think that this is
really a characteristic of populism as I
understand it real mobilization
participation is actually not part of
populism the populist wants the people
as a kind of homogeneous object that
should be represented ideally by the
populist because it's basically one
unified body with one common will aiming
at one common good and therefore capable
of being represented by one party or
even one person but the people don't
really have to be involved so to give
you let me give you another last more
right-wing example think of somebody
like Berlusconi who also very often made
this rhetorical move of essentially
saying you know there's a real Italian
people and then there are these sort of
post communist lefties who don't really
belong and then there are of course
illegal immigrants from Africa and
Romanians and all kinds of other people
who don't really belong to Italy but
about the ideal Berlusconi supporter was
basically somebody who would sit at home
and watch the right TV channels not
somebody who would necessarily go out
into the Piazza and demonstrate and be
very involved civically so I think it's
a mistake to equate
you nism with popular participation or
mobilization but what about a strong
leader Berlusconi is whatever you think
about him is a very charismatic leader
dude a populist movement need a
charismatic leader or for instance the
Tea Party movement is one example where
there isn't any leader is that possible
let's put it this way it helps to have a
charismatic leader to be successful but
that's true across the board in politics
I don't think and again I think I
disagree with a lot of other analysts I
don't think that having a charismatic
leader is really intrinsic to populism
what is intrinsic is the claim that
there is only one popular will and that
that can be successfully embodied by one
person but doesn't have to be very
charismatic necessarily just
symbolically and personally has to be
able to say I truly represent the true
people's will so if I made you if I may
give you another example the post your
Qaeda leader of the Austrian freedom
party who I think was I dare say not a
particularly charismatic person was
always campaigning on the slogan air
danc'd vivia he thinks like us nobody
ever said what he actually thinks but of
course everybody's sort of knew what he
thinks but the point was simply the
claim that here's somebody no matter
what the personal characteristics who
somehow successfully can represent
virtual people but doesn't necessarily
have to be charismatic but it seems like
nobody wants to admit that they are
populist I mean it's it's a term that
nobody will buy into then everybody will
sort of disagree with that is it
necessarily a negative term some people
actually do accept it as a kind of
rhetorical counter-offensive so marine
lepen for instance has said if being a
populist means working and being for the
people I'm a populist Victor Orban the
current leader of Hungary has said if
working for the people and standing up
for the people against the European
Union and global capitalism is being
populists I am a populist so I think
very often
broadly speaking liberal elites actually
set themselves up for a kind of trap
when they completely want to exclude
discussion with populist and stick the
label populist on people and then
populist can come back and say look this
is exactly what our supporters and we
are saying that this establishment has
hijacked the state they don't even want
to talk to us they don't want to engage
with our claims so in that sense simply
sticking a negative label on somebody
actually plays into the hands of actual
populist having said that in let's say
more normative literature on populism I
think there is no positive used for the
term the only positive thing which
sometimes people in my view wrongly say
is that populism could be a kind of
corrective for liberal democracy because
they think it helps more popular
participation I think it doesn't but
that leads me over to the next question
which is I mean is it populism a
political project in itself or is it
simply a political tool I mean can a nun
put a published party use a populist
tool I think a populist to turn it
around a populist party can certainly
use what might at first sight look like
a kind of content or a political set of
ideas that cannot possibly be
appropriated by populist let me give you
another example it's usually said that
liberal populism at least in the
European context must be a contradiction
in terms
because liberalism whatever else you
think about it is about pluralism is
about tolerance populism if you follow
my understanding of it is basically anti
pluralistic there is only one people no
internal difference it's no space for
politics no space for debate and then
somebody like let's say hair builders
comes along in the Netherlands and so of
course speaks in the name of liberalism
speaks in the name of the liberal Dutch
people who are freedom-loving against
well various there
as others so all of a sudden it seems
possible to have a liberal populism but
it's only possible because these liberal
values like freedom freedom of
expression and so on they basically come
to function as identity builders or
identity markers so they're not really
about the values themselves they are
like walls saying this is the proper
Dutch people and their is to put it very
bluntly there is Islam which can never
be liberal which can never be democratic
so what defines the true people is being
against that basically so in that sense
populism is very flexible in what are
appropriate by way of content it's not
but it's not infinitely flexible because
it in my understanding needs to keep
this structure of pitting the one true
homogeneous people with the one
authentic will against the elites and
possibly against those who don't belong
at the bottom of society and then what
is in your opinion the the explanation
for this rise of populism in Europe
after the end of the Cold War
I think the various factors at work in
different contexts I think it didn't
actually even just start with the end of
the Cold War as I've tried to argue in a
in a more historical study Western
European elites after the Second World
War came up with a model or an
understanding of democracy which I've
called constrained democracy because
they drew the lessons from the sort of
catastrophes both catastrophes of mid
twentieth century Europe that popular
sovereignty was actually dangerous thing
in certain ways that even parliamentary
sovereignty was a dangerous thing
because a parliament could actually hand
over all power to a dictator as happened
in 1933 in Germany as happened in 1940
in France so they came up with all kinds
of institutions that were meant to put
certain constraints on popular
sovereignty examples would be
Constitutional Court's examples would
also be something like the European
Council or even the European Union
itself I'm only mentioning this because
in a certain way you might say that in
those countries where this model was
adapted adopted and it wasn't adopted
everywhere it hasn't really been that
successful in the UK or in Denmark from
what I understand but where it was
adopted it presents a kind of standing
invitation to populist actors to say
look in the political system systems we
have the people aren't really present
they're sort of kept at bay they're kept
at a distance and it's time to really
properly bring the people in so we've
seen actually waves off movements
parties that make these sorts of claims
over the course of 20 century European
history in our 21st century European
history in France with puja these were
for instance and then especially in the
1970s with anti-tax parties
anti-immigration parties beyond that
however and this I think gets more to
the post Cold War context we've also
partly because of the end of the Cold
War seen the breakdown of a number of
party systems best example probably
Italy where the entire party system was
really about keeping communists out of
power that breaks down after 1989 and
then obviously the question of who
really represents the people is newly in
play and that's where somebody like
Berlusconi all of a sudden finds a lot
of follicle space over by now sort of 20
year period I mean he's still around as
we all know
I think that's very interesting so
you're saying that actually I mean part
of the problem has been creating those
very institutions which were created
exactly to prevent this from happening
in that's yes in sense yes in a sense a
certain anti populism if you like is in
the if you forgive the biological
metaphor is in the DNA of post-war
European politics so I think it's safe
to put in the DNA of the EU and the DNA
of the EU in particular yes which was
and is an elite project in many in many
ways so I think it's safe to predict
that they're always going to be waves of
populist movements and parties which
will initially make the claim that look
the people aren't really present as I
tried to say earlier they don't really
want popular participation
as such but it gives them a kind of
leverage to start making these these
these sorts of claims and again it's
maybe worth emphasizing that they will
always do so from a moral point of view
it's very noticeable for instance that
when populist s-- lose as they of course
very often do they will never really
concede that the other side actually
really won or is legitimate to give you
one example when Viktor orbán who is now
in power in Hungary lost an election in
2002 he famously or infamously said the
nation cannot be in opposition so even
if empirically the other side won his
party uniquely represented the true
Hungarian nation and by definition the
nation cannot be in opposition to itself
or an example from outside Europe when
the candidate for the Mexican presidency
Lopez Audra Obrador lost in 2006 and
there was a very protraction battle
about the election result he famously
said the victory of the right is morally
impossible
so empirically it's possible they might
have gotten more votes but morally it's
illegitimate and that's a very typically
populist thing to say but to stick to
the European aspect to it or to the EU
angle what if you are a politician
sitting at the in the European
Parliament or in the EU Commission in
Brussels I mean what should be your
concern and and what kind of development
would you sort of put forward in the EU
system to prevent this from from being
just an elite project and maybe feed
into populist movements across Europe
how many hours do we have again so
there's so many things to say about this
and I'll restrict myself to maybe three
of you if you allow me so first of all I
think it's it would be helpful if
European elites themselves distinguished
more carefully between really dangerous
populist and then simply movements and
parties that might make the EU's life
difficult in certain ways but who are
not popular
so my earlier examples the Spanish
indignados and the syriza party there
was a lot of concern what happens if
syriza comes to power but I think would
be wrong to simply in a sense stamp all
these people as populist therefore
negatively label them and then sort of
reinforce a perception that really
European elites don't want to be
bothered with popular claims from below
because indignados are a genuinely
popular movement syriza is a more
complicated story but is also not really
a populist party in the way that I was
describing it earlier so when for
instance in 2010 already the one of the
many European presidents hammer front I
said today populism
is the big problem or danger only to add
that as a Belgian I know what I'm
talking about in certain ways he was
right but it was such a general
statement that it came across like
saying we just want everything to be
quite and we don't want you know popular
mobilizations from below so point number
one more carefully distinguish real
dangers to democracy and other movements
which complicate things but ultimately
could actually be healthy for democracy
because none of these actors who I was
mentioning on the positive side are
really enter European in any in any
meaningful sense so point number one
point number two and this is more
substantial and substantive is that
right now we are in a situation a kind
of interregnum it seems we know that the
old system especially in the euro zone
didn't work cannot go on as it was but
it's not yet clear what a sort of new
settlement will be most politicians are
very very wary now of basically exposing
and exposing themselves risking
something by putting forward a sort of
new grand design for anything but the
worry is that one of the designs that is
emerging clearly looks a little bit like
what some critics have called democracy
without choices by which I mean that
very often it's been said look the
lesson of the euro crisis is that at
least within the euro zone we need to
have very strict rules about budget
deficits about what individual member
states can do so we ideally
constitutionalize debt breaks
we have the European Commission be like
a sort of policeman or as the somewhat
scary German expression then goes a ver
honks camisa who comes along and looks
at your numbers and comes to a judgement
that no this is illegitimate you can't
have a budget like this and so on so we
can dip we can debate the economics of
this but the political problem is that
then very often almost as a kind of
afterthought
people say oh and it also has to be
democratic people have to accept it but
it's very hard to see how such a system
where basically everything is completely
set in stone where there's no real
manoeuvre for national parliaments in
certain ways how that can be democratic
other than in a sort of purely cosmetic
sense that we say okay we might be able
one day to elect the President of the
European Commission and then you can say
oh you know we elected a Social Democrat
and you elected a conservative and so on
but if that person has no political
space to do anything it really becomes
meaningless to speak about democracy so
conversely I would say the best way to
address that given where we are now
would be to actually create some
political space for let's say a European
Commission that in certain regards is a
little bit like a European economic
government so that we're so they're in a
situation hypothetically in the next
European elections you as a European
citizen could say if I were to vote for
again hypothetically martin schulz
as the leader of the Social Democrats
I'm gonna get a somewhat more Keynesian
approach in Europe a growth-oriented one
and if I elect let's say again how
pathetically Donald Tusk I'm gonna get
probably more austerity and a little bit
more German medicine for these
supposedly lazy southerners now it
doesn't mean that thereby we've created
a federal state because it would still
be the Member States who say let's give
a certain amount of leeway for the
Commission to act in different ways to
have different policy options and I
think this is not wildly utopian because
as it happens even the nowadays
much-maligned initial architects of the
euro zone where nowadays everybody says
why didn't they foresee that we were
gonna have these problems why didn't
they see the contradictions in the
project why didn't they see that they
needed to be more coordination some of
them actually expected and I think at
the time quite reasonably that by now
Europe the EU would have a somewhat more
significant budget to address basically
economic imbalances in the eurozone
something like three percent of European
GDP which is not in any way comparable
to what a real federal state would have
but historically is actually
interestingly at more or less the level
that the united states federal
government had in the 19th century so it
was just enough to address major
economic problems to shift money around
appropriately but all this could happen
without actually creating a federal
state except it won't happened because
we are of course living through deeply
euro sceptical times so the last thing
that any major politicians in Europe
monsters of crusade for right now is to
say more money for the EU exactly and
and that's why the whole debate about
Europe Europe's future has been post
because of the partly because of the
German election because nobody wanted to
have that as part our important part of
the German election and the debate in
Germany so my question is I mean
everybody knows the the of course the
huge economic impact from Germany on
what's happening in Europe but what how
do you see Germany more from Italy in it
dick standpoint I mean how do they in
terms of populism and and in that whole
it ideological framework how do you see
Germany there in a certain way even
though now all European I is in a
certain way are on Germany you know the
elections in what most people rightly
think is the most powerful country so
it's very it's very understandable that
most people think the election is very
important at the same time we're not
gonna make a lot of money at the betting
shop by betting on who's gonna be
Chancellor after September 22nd no
because it seems no matter what it's
going to be the same at the same woman
so I think
we're gonna see more change possibly
next year with the European elections
which usually are seen as a kind of
sideshow in all this but it's already
often been the case that the European
elections of course serve as a kind of
outlet for all kinds of national
frustrations you think they don't really
matter all that much so I can vote for
populist parties I can vote for even
enter European parties now think of that
and now add to that the factor that
after the euro crisis I think most
people have realized that
interdependence is real that Europe has
a real effect on their lives that it's
not this distant Brussels thing that you
know cares about how long the bananas
are and otherwise you have to worry
about it but it affects everything the
welfare state taxes everything so you
can imagine a situation where the
outcome of the European elections
produces and at least partially
self-hating European Parliament because
it's full of populist and anti Europeans
so going back to what I talked about a
little bit earlier I think those who say
are more democracy in Europe that must
mean a stronger Parliament they may be
right but they also need to think about
the fact that the Parliament is not
automatically just because it is the
European Parliament going to be
pro-european
so we could end up with a very different
situation in a very different situation
there having said that to come back to
the to come back to the German situation
again we live in a kind of interim I
think nothing is really set in stone yet
about how the eurozone will be governed
and whether Germany will get its the way
there or not
but I think there are in some
indications at the moment that
interestingly the initial German vision
which I hinted at earlier set everything
in stone by law and by Constitution
which by the way is really the German
approach everything has to be done by
law by treaty has to be compatible with
what the German Constitutional Court
says so everything has to be done in
that very legalistic way in a certain
way that project is unlikely to go very
far right now because of the perceived
impossibility of changing the European
treaties most European elites have
decided that at this point it's
impossible it would
ten years you would have to have a
referendum in Ireland they might vote no
it's gonna be like the last decade where
things drag on forever the perception
will deepen that Europe is dysfunctional
or that if you vote no NA referendum you
will have to vote again until you
finally vote yes so people are very much
trying away from that and then there is
of course the United Kingdom which has
now committed itself very strongly to
saying as soon as we open up you know
the the current package the current
settlement we want a better deal
so the legalistic proposal is unlikely
to go very far right now so what is
instead emerging but I don't think it's
anybody's design I don't think it was a
long-term plan that anybody had is
almost a kind of parallel universe to
the EU which you maybe could call the
the Euro land so to speak which already
has a couple of institutions like the
European Stability Mechanism and others
which is really much more about national
governments coordinating and cooperating
and working out pacts and deals and so
on and so forth and that's if you wanted
to put a national cliched label on it
that's actually much more like the
French approach because it gives a lot
of discretionary power to governments to
executives it's sort of running Europe
via the nation state governments and the
European Commission has been very much
sidelined in this in this process I
don't think this is what Angela Merkel
wanted but I think this is some of the
best she can get right now to stabilize
things from the point of view of
democracy it poses even more problems
then the actual existing EU structure
has because there is even more going on
behind closed doors even harder to see
who is accountable for certain certain
decisions but this is what we might end
up with and this is also the one thing
that absolutely is not being debated
right now
in the German elections so if this model
turns out not to work it could really
come to haunt especially the German
political establishment because people
might come back and say look why did we
never talk about this we never signed
really up to this kind of proposal but
right now everybody is so afraid of
risking something by touching this that
essentially the only all-out Pro
European integration party as you know
are the Greens
and they're currently going down in the
polls you talked earlier people about
Eastern Europe and populism in Eastern
Europe but since the the euro crisis
broke out especially focus has been on
southern Europe as well I mean with huge
social problems I mean for instance
Spain I think they have unemployment
around 60% among young people in Spain
and so on
I mean are you worried about populism in
southern Europe I am we clearly already
have seen in Greece the rise of a party
that is not only populist but it's
all-out fascist and that keeps going up
in the polls so the golden the Golden
Dawn party in Greece in Italy I think
Grillo's movement is very ambiguous I
think Grillo in some pronouncements is
like a populist when Grillo says we want
nothing less than a hundred percent in
Parliament that for me is a populist and
in that sense negative statement because
no true Democrat wants a hundred percent
you know Stalin wants a hundred percent
but you know a Democrat knows that
they're always going to be differences
ongoing conflict and so on and so forth
at the same time I think Grillo has put
a lot of issues on the agenda which
should be on the agenda so I think
that's a true borderline case between
dangerous populism and a good corrective
to democracy in Spain interestingly the
party protocol landscape hasn't changed
all that much but instead of a new party
of course we might see a new country
because in many ways the pressure that
has been building up has found an outlet
in the secessionist movement in
Catalonia now what do they all
nevertheless have in common I think what
they have in common is that in certain
ways nothing less then the overall
political settlement or if you like the
social contract of these countries is at
stake that APRI in a previously existing
understanding of what the country was
about the kind of overall bargain struck
between different groups how the state
should look like all that has been up
for question the euro crisis in a sense
triggered this development but it's not
the ultimate cause
the euro crisis is not the cause of
let's say an overextended Greek state
the cause of an overextended Greek said
is also not that you know as German
tabloids like to have it the Greeks are
lazy and like to live off the state know
the real historical reason is that Greek
had a civil war and that a typical
answer to pacifying a society after a
civil war is to extend your state and
give both political sides enough jobs in
the state basically the same that
Austria after 1945 but it just didn't
lead to the same kinds kinds of problems
so I think the problem is that in in all
these countries right now an old social
contract is no longer seen as legitimate
a new one hasn't emerged yet and more
worrying perhaps it's not really clear
how a new one could be authorized what
would be a good mechanism for a society
to say okay we've come to a new
understanding how we want to live
sometimes this might work because you
have a grand coalition of all parties
saying look we really have to move
forward together we are all on board for
this on board for this we're all in this
together and you might at first side say
well that's actually how it looks like
right now in Greece in Italy because you
have parties which were always
completely at loggerheads currently in
grand coalition's you would never have
thought that Berlusconi's party and the
left could ever cooperate yet they do
you would never have thought that the
Greek left and New Democracy the
right-wing party could cooperate yet
they do the problem is if you are a
Greek or Italian citizen I think this
doesn't look to you like oh this is a
great founding moment for a new social
contract I think to you this looks much
more like the old parties who had
basically hijacked the state and divided
it amongst themselves now in a moment of
crisis aren't forgetting all the
ideological differences and working
together to hold on to this old model so
I think it doesn't look good on that
score the alternative or people can also
imagine as a way to sort of engineer a
moment of refoundation and finding a new
social contract might be to think about
crafting a new constitution and we've
seen some examples of this to think of
the alas ill-fated it's seen
Icelandic so-called crowd-sourced
Constitution where there was a sense
after the financial crisis that the old
establishment had so badly managed
things that the old social contract was
no longer legitimate that you really
needed to hand it back to the people in
a certain way the same was tried in
Ireland where there stood an ongoing
constitutional process with a
constitutional convention where people
were randomly selected from different
parts of the country to sit in this
convention alas I think in both cases by
now it's safe to say that there's a very
strong perception that the old
establishment parties have come back and
have either stopped this process as in
Iceland or they've essentially hijacked
it and made it very harmless as an
Ireland but when you talk about creating
a new constitution you mean a national
Constitution yes or or but what about a
he you Constitution a different EU
Constitution so again that goes back to
the whole question of a grant design I
think that in theory you might say that
we are much closer now to a real
constitutional moment then let's say ten
years ago when European elites were
spending years and years you know with
great fanfare actually crafting a
constitutional treaty and convincing you
know national populations that we now
absolutely need this constitution for
Europe to work well the Constitution was
voted down in two founding members of
the EU and the world didn't collapse and
the EU didn't collapse so it seems you
know that the constitutional moment that
was bandied about at that time wasn't
really a constitutional moment it was
really just another attempt to kind of
sell Europe to the people and in a very
awkward and ultimately unsuccessful way
there was no real substantive reason why
there had to be a constitutional treaty
back then now you might say it's really
the opposite there really needs to be a
new if you like social contract as well
and cross the eurozone as a whole
because people have woken up to the fact
of interdependence what we do here
matters over there what they do over
there matters over here ii-if even tiny
Greece can bring down the whole
structure we need to kind of find ways
of coordinating our
we need to factor into it need to factor
into our national politics what they do
and in a sense our national politics
need to understand what effects our
decisions have on have on them so in a
sense would be much better moment now to
think of a new constitutional mechanism
that and allows that sort of
coordination to take place in a
legitimate an ideally democratic way but
as I try to say earlier the elites are
so afraid right now of opening up this
can of worms that as soon as you
mentioned the c-word
you know people polite you sort of push
you out of the room because everybody is
still so traumatized by the last
Constitution making process and
everybody thinks that in any case
practically even treaty change isn't
possible right now so where does that
leave us well it in a sense of actually
then throws it back to European citizens
to say well look we actually want a
really explicit settlement and we don't
want this parallel euro land universe
where we don't really understand what's
going on
we don't really understand who's in
charge we don't know who to hold
accountable so ultimately in a sense it
falls back on European citizens well I
guess Denmark is not in the you're not
in the eurozone so I shouldn't blame you
but for those of you who might be in the
eurozone here I think now is the time to
say that look we would like to see this
done differently and and what is the
right approach for the establishment as
you call it or the elite I mean to deal
with populist movements I mean as you
gave a few examples of them actually
working together on a national level is
that the right approach to embrace them
or I think the the important thing is
not to indirectly play into the hands of
populist by acting in exactly the way
that populist would predict elites act
so to simply dismiss them and say well
you're a populist I'm not talking to you
you're a populist I'm not even listening
to what kind of complaints and arguments
and problems you want to bring into the
pokel arena so I think a kind of
engagement is always the right answer as
long as you're not dealing with parties
that let's say openly embrace violence
so again I think it's important to
distinguish between different from
I think golden dawn in Greece is a party
that ideally should be banned I mean I
don't think there should be neo-nazi
party is openly competing in in in
European politics but that's not for me
to decide I think that's a question that
can be decided at at national level but
I think for populous it would be a
populist the right strategy is not just
sort of high-handed dismissal but to say
look let's engage what actual arguments
do you have not to buy into their image
of the true people but to really bring
it down to arguments and facts now you
can say that's very rationalistic that's
a typical sort of idealistic academic
dream that the better argument will win
out and so on so forth
but it seems to mean the wrong strategy
to say are we gonna out-compete them on
the level of passions or we're gonna
show that we truly represent the people
and they don't because I don't think
you're gonna win that game so you
started by saying that you were actually
worried about what's happening in
southern Europe and maybe in Eastern
Europe as well
I mean what's to you is the the
nightmare scenario unfortunately I have
many nightmares it's not always the same
but but I look I mean let me let me
preface the answer by saying that I
don't mean to sound like you know it's
euro AK apocalypse now that you know
we're just of a step away from a sort of
I'm our style collapse of liberal
democracies across Europe or anything
like anything like that I don't think
that's the case but I think we are even
if in the eurozone things were to stay
calm I think we are still in for a
number of rough years within individual
countries and possibly across the EU as
a whole because it's very hard to see
how in southern Europe people will
arrive at a new legitimate settlement
and it's very hard to see how at least
in some central Eastern European
countries a kind of basic liberal
democratic consensus which held for a
number of years after 1989 at least in
some countries can be properly restored
I think there the situation is a little
bit different in that you don't actually
necessarily have a lot of polarization
at the level of popular
but you have political establishments
which are deeply antagonistic and split
and we're basically a lot of the times
the legitimacy of one's main opponent is
denied so you see that for instance in
Hungary where the government says the
Socialists aren't really properly
representing hungry you see this in
Romania you now see this in Bulgaria and
even in the Czech Republic which again
have been one of these sort of Paragons
of liberal democratic virtue for a while
after 89 in the last couple of months
we've seen an almost why must our
confrontation between a directly elected
president who claims that he truly
represents the people and then the
Parliament so this is not you know
day-to-day porca conflict where you can
say oh well you know people are a bit at
each other's throats but you know it'll
it'll be fine these are fairly systemic
problems sometimes but not always rooted
in poor culture if we didn't have the
euro crisis right now I think a lot of
us especially European elites would be
much more worried about this they would
see a pattern and they would say it's
not just one bad apple Oh Hungary is
doing something funny but that's just
one weird guy everything else is fine no
it's much more widespread it's a general
phenomenon and even in a sort of by now
a sort of sort of showcase for success
like Poland where everybody says look
this is a fantastic European success
story economically the only country
since the financial crisis that has been
growing all the way through seems to
have a stable political system right now
and so on even there the remaining
Kachinsky is making a comeback now
imagine a country as big as Poland
joining the others in this category all
of a sudden I think people would realize
look we thought you know after accession
to the EU everybody was living you know
on the island of the blessed forever
after and it's not true so in other
words you're saying we're focusing on
the wrong conflict or the wrong problem
the eurozone problems are real and
that's why in a sense we that's why I
was talking also about about problems in
the south but I think because this has
been so much in in the Meuse and we've
been limping from
some into crisis summit I think it's
been easier to not so much worry about
these other situations of course there's
also a fair amount of if I may say so
prejudice involved that there was always
a sense that well these countries are
only half European anyway so we're not
so surprised that you know that
democracies aren't working out so well
but it's worth remembering that the
great promise of the EU was almost was
always a suit you know as soon as you
declared ready to join the club you are
a fully certified proper liberal
democracy if you're in you will of
course stay in as you know a properly
liberal democratic country because why
would you ever want to go back to any
kind of other system and that promise
that hope has turned out to be an
illusion and could you imagine any of
the current EU member states actually
taking the consequence and leaving the
European Union it's very hard to see
right now that anybody would actually
take that final take that final
consequence it's maybe worth also
pointing out that actually nobody could
be made to leave legally right now a
country is of course allowed to
voluntarily leave you and that was often
trumpeted as a great achievement of the
Lisbon Treaty that now was possible to
kind of basically politely say goodbye
to the club and and do your own thing
but if you saw a massive deterioration
in liberal democracy in a Member State a
number of sanctions would be available
to the EU but you couldn't actually take
the ultimate step and say you are a
military dictatorship now you must leave
and again I think we don't have that
option because people thought it could
never possibly happen why would anybody
ever want to do anything anything like
that now just one last point on this I
think the most worrying development in
this regard in terms of a an actual
political leader who is exercising power
right now at least keeping that option
on the table I think is Hungary's Victor
Orbin who in a sense has has pursued a
strategy which many observers have found
irrational because if you look at polls
and
many people remain fairly pro-eu so what
he is what has sometimes been called his
war of independence independence from us
that is has not been terribly popular
but the thought is that maybe he wants
to keep that option in the background of
one day saying look this club of you
know the EU which is of course run by
German and Austrian multinationals and
which is against you know the interest
of the true Hungarian people is
detrimental and we ought to come we
ought to leave it's not completely
impossible before we leave the EU and in
Europe for a while I'd like you to also
bring in the news media I mean in in
terms of populism you said earlier that
that we are basically focusing too
little on populist movements and too
much on the euro crisis is how do you
see that the news media which is rapidly
changing these years as well how do you
say see them play into that whole new
development I think it's I think there
the issue is no different than the issue
for political elites in general that I
think responsible news coverage involves
a certain ability to draw distinctions I
mean ultimately you could even say what
it means to have good poker judgment is
to be able to distinguish different
phenomena and not label everything with
the same term because it's convenient
because that's just lazy and you don't
look closely at what a party or a
movement is actually is actually doing
so I think the best that can be hoped
for is that journalists as well trying
to form as comprehensive a picture about
individual phenomena and then say well a
certain label really does apply to them
or maybe it actually doesn't because at
first it might look like they're
populist of a certain stripe but
actually but actually they're not but in
that sense that's not exclusive to
journalists either because ideally all
citizens would invest in forming good
political judgments which also means you
can never simply
so they'll have a pre-existing model or
the civics textbook and say ah they fit
this model okay you know check but but
that's right but you can also say well
just ten years ago news media were very
much controlled by the elite I mean
newspapers television stations and so on
but now I mean the news media can also
be populist in the sense that everybody
is a journalist today you can write on
Twitter you can write on I mean Facebook
in the whole social media has sort of
democratized the whole news business so
that creates also a different picture
where the the news media is not
necessarily establishment anymore yes
but this in a certain way would help my
anti populist argument because the
populist would always claim we
exclusively represent and speak for the
people and if there many other actually
existing people who say something
different that helps the argument that
society is actually much more complex
and differentiated then the person who
says everybody who is the true people
thinks basically like me and so in that
sense I'm not so pessimistic I mean
they've always been tabloids in in
Europe and and elsewhere that hasn't
changed hasn't gotten any better it
hasn't gotten any worse so I think more
diversity and more possibilities for
people to articulate themselves in a
certain way even though for other people
that's exactly populist because you know
the people say stupid things but on my
account
that's actually helpful for countering
populist claims for exclusive
representation and showing that they're
actually wrong I know that most of your
research and your writings have been
focusing on Europe particularly but I
think it's it's difficult to have this
talk without bringing in the Middle East
because everybody now is following
what's happening in Syria I mean the
Arab Spring has been quite a right for
people to follow what happened in Egypt
where everybody was sort of optimistic
about Arab Spring and here again you had
a wouldn't labor early populistic
movement but at least you had people
revolting the establishment and then
they elected a leader and that wasn't
acceptable I mean how do you see
the development in the Middle East with
with with sort of the framework of your
published theory well you're very polite
to say that wasn't acceptable because
the question is of course it wasn't
acceptable to whom exactly and and why
but in my in my framework I would say
that the Arab the Arab Spring was a real
popular moment a real real moment of
popular participation where people came
out they actually unlike my earlier
example about Berlusconi and people
staying at home and watching TV
of course they really did come out to
the squares and they made the claim that
people also famously made in 1989 that
they really were the people and that
those who spoke for them didn't speak
for them it's very different to make
that claim in a dictatorship than to
make their claim in a liberal democracy
that might have all kinds of
deficiencies and faults but we're you
know populist we'll say we exclusively
represent the real people whereas an
indicator ship to say look we are the
people and those in power and who never
asked us actually don't represent us so
that a quite different logic applies
there and there was really popular
participation however you could say that
the Muslim Brotherhood then actually
pursued a program that was populist in
my sense in the sense that they crafted
a constitution that they tried to impose
a settlement that was predicated on the
idea that only those who were like the
Muslim Brotherhood really had a place in
Egypt that only their they were the true
Egyptian people and everybody else had
to be excluded or marginalized or had to
have some kind of detrimental
detrimental outcome so in that sense I
think in their in that's in that
specific sense populism populism applies
and that effort failed so far but in a
sense the challenge remains how you can
find again coming back to this earlier
language how you can find a social
contract where all the contending groups
in society can say okay this is a
settlement we can live with and this is
not simply one part of society lording
it over the other part of society
because as long as that is the
perception you're never going to have a
stable liberal democratic
framework now and that writes the
question are we in the West ready to
accept true drama democracy in the
Middle East meaning we're only accepting
it as long as a outcome is we is what we
what we hope for we like to see it well
it's one it's it's I mean CLE there have
been instances and that has been the
usual pattern for a long time that yes
people would officially say of course we
are for democracy but actually testily
were very happy with Mubarak style
characters because they you know keep a
lid on all kinds of extremist phenomena
I think by now everybody hopefully would
have understood that this was profoundly
mistaken because the Mubarak cell
characters didn't keep a lid on
phenomena they were of course tacitly
encouraging this phenomena because that
was their at best justification for ever
to stay in power so I think it was
always a profound mistake to think that
Oh occasionally we support dictators
because they prevent you know worse
things from happening they always were
encouraging keeping alive and
encouraging worse things because that
was their best claim to power so I don't
think we should go back to anything like
that for normative reasons but even if
you're a very hard most realist you
should have understood that this doesn't
actually doesn't actually it doesn't
actually work right now in general I
think it's maybe will be seen 50 years
from now as historians start writing
about our present you know they will
probably write a little bit about the
eurozone crisis but they might also come
to the conclusion that actually the
truly momentous development of our time
was the Arab Spring something that
happened not in some faraway corner of
the world but right on Europe's doorstep
and that Europe essentially slept
through this development and there was
just the kind of lazy excuse to say are
we shouldn't be so involved because
there's all this colonial baggage and
this you know traumatic past so yes you
know we'll help a little bit but you
know we don't really want to be too
involved in all this
clearly you know the EU is not going to
offer membership to Egypt tomorrow but I
think this complete completely
standoffish
contrast strikingly and I would say
tragically with the stance that the EU
took in the late 1980s and early 1990s
because you could have said very similar
things then you could have said our
Centre in Eastern Europe has always been
very unstable you know other Balkans
already at war again you know the
Germans shouldn't be involved because
think of the legacy of the Second World
War so they shouldn't really try to do
anything there and so on and so forth so
I think it's in many ways just too lazy
excuse it says something about Europe's
weakness and unwillingness to really
think beyond you know the birthday but
having said that don't you think it has
something to do with the fact that we
have been fighting two very expensive
Wars I mean the one in Afghanistan and
one in Iraq so there is a certain
fatigue at least if you talk about Syria
to go in and be active again I'm not
saying that we should you know send out
the troops and and and fight lots of
wars in the in in the Middle East but I
think by now the U has both knowledge
and resources as far as questions of how
do you enable a successful transition to
liberal democracy is concerned now of
course it has been somewhat involved I
don't want to be completely dismissive
but in general this is something that
officially has been treated with a great
deal of distance and it's not really
been something that politicians have
tried to bring to the table in European
discussions now I understand that this
is again not a winning proposition I
mean if you're a politician right now I
understand that apart from all your
other worries you don't want to say by
the way I've got a couple of great ideas
about the Middle East I know that's not
a vote well vote winner but again think
back to the early 90s there was enough
prejudice in Europe to say what you mean
you know we're gonna be in the same club
as you know Poland Hungary Romania about
the area all these faraway countries you
know all the all the kind of mental maps
of the Cold War which younger
generations I think have completely
forgotten rightly so and it's a good
thing but if you lived through that time
as a politician you had to take somewhat
of a risk and say look we want to we
want all them to be in the club we want
to do something proactive it's gotta
cost something it's going to be an
effort
take time and so on so I think that
should be a more inspiring example and
even though it contradicts a little bit
what I said earlier because I talked
about the fact that actually accession
wasn't just a complete success story
that we were seeing a certain amount of
reverse trends in a number of countries
still overall
I think it's an amazing European
achievement and it's something that we
should make more of I think before we
wrap up we have about five minutes left
I think we'd like I'd like to talk about
America United States and and we talked
about both national constitutions in in
in Europe but also the European
Constitution and I like you to elaborate
a little bit about the American
Constitution because I mean that was
partly created by the founding fathers
actually to prevent populism and it has
created a system where no nothing is
happening no decisions are made because
they are stucked in there
checks and balances and the Congress
doesn't speak to the White House and
it's completely frozen politically but
how do you see the American experiment
from again from from the trying to
prevent populism from happening well
it's sort of it's both the worst of all
possible worlds and it's the best of all
possible worlds it's the best of all
possible worlds just to start on the
positive side in the sense that I mean
they have been waves and waves of
populist movements in the United States
this is not a new phenomenon and the Tea
Party isn't the first populist movement
and yet the system has found ways of
dealing with them of absorbing them
without in a sense mainstream parties
simply becoming necessarily populist
themselves so there are many flaws in
the American system there are many legal
scholars who by now say look if only we
could get rid of this Constitution you
know it was great for the 18th century
but by the way it has all kinds of flaws
because it was a constitution for a
society that had slavery there are all
kinds of issues that bring about the
situation you described in terms of
gridlock a society where long term
problems can't be addressed and so on
fourth so there is actually kind of
developing discussion about how the
Constitution should not be venerated as
a kind of quasi sacred object but
ideally should be thrown out don't worry
it's not gonna happen but there is it
there is a meaningful discussion about
about its flaws so it's not just all you
know completely uncritical uncritical
patriotism but at the same time I think
you can credit the system not just with
stability but with a certain capacity
for absorption so that was the good news
the bad news is of course that right now
we're seeing a situation where one party
over the last over recent history really
has massively in a sense adopted a
certain kind of populism and so
Republicans and the Tea Party and
whereas when many people say Oh u.s.
politics is so much more polarized now
it's not quite true because that implies
an image you know where both parties
sort of move to the extreme but the
Democratic Party hasn't moved to any
kind of extreme the Democratic Party
remains wonderfully friendly to Wall
Street etc etc right it's the Republican
Party that has adopted a completely
destructive stance of course in in
Congress but also committed itself
ideologically in certain ways where it's
very hard to see how they're going to
reverse themselves anytime anytime and
you you think that is because of the Tea
Party yes I think that's well it's
partly it's partly a strategy simply to
say ok we're going to oppose this
president as much as we can so we're not
we're not going to enable him to take
any credit for any achievement wherever
wherever we can and unfortunately of
course by now we have a we have a we
have a situation where as you know the
already existing checks and balances in
a sense through now established
practices like the filibuster have
become even more severe so that now it's
accepted that actually you need me of a
higher majority in the Senate to get
every to get anything anything done so
the system is not becoming unfrozen it's
becoming even more frozen in certain
ways and you combine that where the
party that is set on basically on a kind
of destructive course and is willing to
stick to these very strong
commitments.the hope just to end on a
more hopeful note is of course that they
realize at one point that electorally
this is not a winning strategy that
actually given what has now been often
debated given the changing demographics
of the country given certain long-term
trends yes you can always lock in this
one strong if you like populist
constituency but overall that's not
gonna win you elections and sooner or
later every rational politician is going
to worry about that that most
unfortunate to be the last word we've
been talking for an hour it's has been a
great pleasure thank you very very
interesting thank you very much thank
you
you